[Music]
this is session cmp 202 and it will be
talking about high performance computing
HPC partner ecosystem at Google cloud
you can submit your questions and
comments on Tori and if you're not
familiar with Tori yet you have a
neighbor turn to your left or turn to
your right
and we're sure you know there there are
some Dory experts in the audience and
also did you know you know that you can
also sum up or thumb down some Dory
comments or anybody else's Dory comments
and so the most popular Dory comments
will be pushed up to top of the queue
and that would really get our attention
so let's get it started
my name is Michelle Shu I'm with Google
clouds global technology partnership
team my job is to make sure that Google
cloud and our partners work together and
it would deliver solutions so the end
users can adopt cloud easily quickly and
cost-effectively and some of our
partners are here today with me
spoiler alert we have couple demos so
we'll begin with a personal story I was
an engineer I was a graduate student I
studied optics integrated circuits
optical communication and a later atomic
physics so scientific computation is
very much near and dear to my heart and
thinking back more than a decade ago
when I was running simulations I only
really had a couple of choices right
either I run a very rudimentary
simulation compressed on my own desktop
or I can submit the 3d jobs the very
complex the real problems into a data
center
and then how the way then a queue for a
week time has changed all of these
machines are available at our fingertips
and why Google Cloud Google's data
center and our cloud has supported many
bees businesses to grow and some of
these businesses are owned you might
know that we have a search engine and
we'll have a platform where people can
share and publish videos and we also
help eat people to exchange emails all
of these businesses have grown over the
years and each business has more than 1
billion customers today so our track
record is pretty good right our track
record to help businesses to grow is
pretty good and there's no magic it is
all in the investment we have made in
our data centers in our facilities so
underneath it all we customized a lot of
things we customized buzz taps so we can
supply a lot of power into our data
center we customized cooling systems we
even put machine learning so then our
data center can run even more
efficiently so for example let's take
PUA right power usage effectiveness it
is the ratio of the total amount of
power you put into a data center divided
by the amount of power consumed by IT
equipments so in the perfect world
PUA is what 1 right and now if we take
any data standard around the world
the industry norm to run the data center
is 1.5 which means every 1.5 power you
put into the data center and only one
watt is used for IT equipment and at
Google because of our investments
we're so good at running efficient data
centers our PUA is 1.1 in addition to
the data center investment we also want
to make sure that our data centers are
connected all around the world so we
invest in subsea optical cables and used
to picture of our engineering team
laying down the tables their total 13 of
them around the world and they're both
underneath the Atlantic as well as the
Pacific Oceans and these cables are so
long that we even need a putty and
repeaters so then we can reap umph the
optical power periodically and the
investment doesn't just stop there in
the past three years we have invested 47
billion dollars we serve more than 1
billion IP addresses every day we have
5000 cashing points and our machine
uptime is four nines here are some
additional statistics about our
infrastructure we have 19 regions and
our track record is we have been growing
five to six regions every year feel free
to take a photo here's a vigil which is
putting all of the statistics on this
map and the point about this as I
mentioned time has changed engineers no
longer need to worry about where the
computers are where they're located what
size they are and wait weeks in the
queue all of these machines this entire
infrastructure you're seeing here on the
map it's available to you from your
laptop and the infrastructure is offered
to you as services or products from
Google Cloud
we have a wide category of compute
networking storage products software
service etc and we're continuously
making new products every day
and so this week in the past couple days
you might have already heard a lot of
product new product announcements
instead of going through the entire
catalog I picked out a few that I
thought this particular crowd might be
interested so during the keynote we
talked about two new machine types C 2
and M 2 C 2 is the compute optimized
compute engine that can go up to 3.8
gigahertz and the M 2 is a memory
optimized compute engine and they can go
up to 12 terabytes
so imaginary you have some scale up
crazy simulations these two machines
might come in very very handy and
knowing that our product catalog is
pretty wide so our product manager Hanan
organized a session yesterday so this is
the second QR code organized a session
yesterday to give you a walkthrough of
our entire GCE product catalog and also
to show you how to pair each one of our
machines to the specific use case that
you're interested in I picked the third
talk that is storage and the storage is
special because the storage focus on HPC
systems so again you might be interested
as well and the last one I picked is on
cost savings you know that is always a
hot topic you may or may not have missed
these sessions if you have that is okay
because they're gonna be available
online for you to look at so with all of
these services and tools available to
you you already have everything you need
to run your HPC workloads and if you're
interested to you know not DIY but also
choose a partner product we also have a
lot of partners in the HPC ecosystem
that are currently working with us so
for example we have systems integrator
partners we have storage partners
we have HPC application and partners and
what we mean by HPC application is for
example in CAE you have old hair right a
famous CAE
vendor or in EDA would have synopsis and
we also are working with job scheduler
partners so that they can help us to
manage the entire infrastructure for
customers and today we would like to
show you know seeing is believing we
would like to show you a couple of
partners solutions and let's jump into
it Google cloud has made nvidia gpus
available through our platform and you
know in the past I would not have
imagined to be able to render anything
on the cloud and the way we enable GPU
through our cloud is to make sure that
we set them set up the GPUs and that
passed through mode and so that the
performance is bare metal performance
and also because the flexibility of the
cloud you can attach GPUs to any
instances and then you can mix match the
configurations of your infrastructure
for example a different memory different
CPU and different and Vidya SKU types
and here are the list of immediate GPU
types we have available on GPU I don't
GCP and each one of them is targeted for
a very specific type of use case for
example if you're looking at a more
memory bound or compute bound a kind of
problems and you might want to pick a
specific GPU that satisfies your need
and today we actually have t4 skew GA
today and they're available globally in
amia America as well as a pack they're
available in age regions and so t4 is
very good at solving memory bound
problems and we'll have Edward here from
Nvidia demonstrating the power of T for
today
welcome by the way today we're going to
show some of the power of using nvidia
on google cloud the demo we have to show
you is a dwarf star explosion and so you
you might use some large compute to take
this radio telescope data to crunch it
in FB 64 using our vault a line or a
pascal line of supercomputer GPUs and
then in this case here we want to
visualize it to get some insight and so
because in video has T fors in the cloud
I can spin up instances and in this
particular workload it's a memory bound
problem to visualize it in a way to get
inside it's not a compute bound problem
so the T 4 is actually a perfect balance
for that for that job so I chose GeForce
but it's a very large amount of data
it's a couple of terabytes that you need
to be processing in real time to be able
to visualize it and so what we do is we
use a Nvidia product called index which
is able to do volumetric rendering
across many nodes in many GPUs so
actually have 144 jobs running as a
cluster I make a in an instance group
and then I just deployed click to deploy
and I get 36 nodes of 40 floors each
just pushed out into the cloud and then
I have a web server able to connect to
it so if we jump across to my laptop I
can show you a demo and before I put the
mic down I'll just explain a little bit
about what you're seeing here so this is
the the data set we have and the colors
are matched to different frequencies
that are detected by the radio telescope
and there's sort of two dimensions to
that we have the top coloring which is
how you want to visualize the frequency
and then the second dimension of that is
for the given amount of energy of that
particular frequency of that particular
particle we can change the color map as
well so I'll let Michelle speak to a
little bit more about some of the
astrophysics fun and I'll start playing
with it and showing you how you can see
different components it's more than just
the visualization right each of this
this diagram is being done using a
hundred and forty-four
Ochs think of it cubes but it's more
than just making it look pretty it's
about finding insight and so I'm going
to show you how you can interactively do
that by changing the parameters to see
different interesting features so this
is a supernova explosion and you may or
may not know the actual physics behind
it you know when the star is dying near
the end of its life instead of just
quietly going away they explode they
could explode and so what you're looking
at is different type of elements and
particles through a being thrown away
from the center of the explosion and and
I believe yeah I was highlighting
certain part of the elements that's been
you know so from a physicists
perspective you know they can select
different part of the spectrum to reveal
on this live simulation and so then they
can know how different particles
interact with each other the trajectory
of their ejection angles profile and all
sorts of scientific insights they can
gain from this life simulation so here's
a fun fact oh this is great yeah this is
this is the Foley that's a pre-recorded
fully and fully compiled you know 360
view of a supernova they're able to find
the insights and have spectacularly
found those components to show us and so
a little fun fact as as you're watching
this plate live so there's a star called
Betelgeuse it's only 600 light years
away from us ambu juice is so big that
when they experienced a supernova which
scientists do believe is gonna go it's
gonna explode
soonish you know and if
and when that happens in our life time
when everybody I was is looking at
there's a bright blob in the sky and you
know all of us here where we can be safe
ya know been there done that we've seen
that I Google cloud next right in 2019
that was amazing everyone give a round
applause for Edward and NVIDIA was
beautiful
cool
that was one of many amazing things we
can do with GPU in the cloud we have
more than 600 GPU accelerated apps in
available on our marketplace and and
each one of and all of these apps are
categorized into different verticals and
I Google Cloud it would have different
vertical teens that are very specialized
and knowledgeable about a how the
workload in each one of these categories
work and so I'd love to hear from you
after the talk connect and I would love
to introduce you to our area and domain
experts so they can help you to identify
how to best run your workload on Google
cloud and out of these 600 GPU
accelerated HPC apps more than 50 of
them are in containers right we all like
containers because you know you build
ones run everywhere easy to deploy
easier to manage here's our second demo
from a firm couple we're partners
actually do we all know what pre-emptive
will be ends are can I see a show of
hands frame the VMS nice good nice for
those who those who don't know what p.m.
pre-emptive VM is the name itself is
quite self-explanatory there is a
trade-off right you can spawn a VM and
there's with preemptable VMs or
trade-off
you can take risk of jobs being
preempted and at the same time you can
enjoy the cost saving of these
preemptable yen's
and I can see some of people are already
shaking their heads because you know
engineers do not want to launch
thousands of batch jobs and wake up in
the morning knowing that jobs are not
done when we set up the our entire
infrastructure with a go scheduler and a
good file system in the backend even
when the VMS are preempted the job
scheduler can recognize the PM the jobs
are being preempted and save the current
state of the job in the file system in
the backend and then put the job back in
the queue and respawn it somewhere else
and a remount the file system and let's
welcome david from alaska file and Brian
from scat MD to show us how to
seamlessly manage your preempted jobs on
Google Cloud thanks Michelle so we are
going to show you today to put it in
context this last year Christmas
happened in December like it does every
year and I had something interesting
happen I've been married for 20 years
and so my 20th Christmas with my bride
and I got a gift that I never expected
to receive on Christmas usually it's a
sweater or socks or something like that
and this year I open this package and I
got a Rustler 4x4 VXL brushless Traxxas
remote-control car amazing right I did
not expect this thank you that's a
reward for 20 years of marriage I guess
but it was really fun something a toy
I have children but something I could
play with and it would be amazing so I
live I live in the great white north of
Minnesota where it's snowy all the time
so I took this out over the last few
months and put it to work and I want to
show you what it looks like when it runs
[Music]
all right tons of fun we had a great
time playing with these toys so later
that weekend my 17 year old son said let
me play with it so right behind what you
just saw is a hockey rink which is pure
ice if you don't live in a place that's
cold so he goes out the sun's coming
down and he's ripping away with the car
and he gets like kind of into the
distance and all the sudden I hear a
thud and it stops right no good
everything was broken he ran straight
into a fire hydrant at probably 40 miles
an hour right so I take the car home and
I want to fix it and I'm pretty good at
fixing cars I've been doing this my
whole life have a whole garage full of
tools and nothing works
everything's miniature I don't have no
replacement parts I have no tools that
fit these little and you know tiny
screws and everything so I'm out of
commission for several weeks and I had
to go get schematics and figure out how
to rebuild these systems I had to go
order tools and replacement parts and
all of that and so essentially 3-4 weeks
later I had built an entire tool bench
to manage this gift that I got for
Christmas but I got it back up and
running better than ever and it's
amazing and doing great today so I
shared this story with you because I
think it's it's consistent with the
experience I've heard from a lot of our
customers that they've worked with is
they've tried to take high-performance
applications from how they're running on
Prem today and into the cloud and we get
really excited about the engine the
tools the you know preemptable VMS and
containers and you know automatic
scheduling all this great stuff that can
happen in the cloud and often we get
there and we get started and then we
figure out my tools in my garage aren't
quite compatible with what's out there
in the cloud so we came together and
this is really what we've been working
on jointly with Google cloud with the
sket and D folks with slurm in Alaska
file we're really here to take a lot of
that complexity out of the equation and
try to shorten the gap between
do today and what you might do in cloud
and so we want to show you how this
works we put together a demo this sort
of simply architected like this it's
running in a Google project completely
slurm will be will be stood up we're
going to deploy a whole bunch of VMs
preemptable VMs actually will use the
lasso file for the backend storage and
we actually have an application that we
authored called Iran which does you know
a pretty intense type of storage load
generation and we're gonna show you what
happens as we go okay so I want to have
Bryan come up and he's going to actually
not yet so let me break down the
components real quickly for you that
that are going to happen so on the alasa
file side if you don't know us what we
are is essentially a scale out file
system that's designed to operate
essentially natively inside of Google
Cloud okay which it's a it presents as
an NFS server really simple no
client-side software needed standard NFS
you've been using for 10 20 30 years but
on the back end it's a highly
distributed file system that handles
embarrassingly parallel connections
really well it runs completely inside of
Google Cloud so any region any zone it
can stand up and run in a mere matter of
minutes you know the the system like I
said it's NFS v3 it's designed to handle
it's scale out so as you need more
capacity you scale horizontally you need
more performance you scale horizontally
and then when you're done with that
performance the capacity you can shrink
it back in which actually works it's
elastics in and out so it's designed to
get to large capacities integrated for
with Google Cloud storage so it can tear
as you as your data gets cooler and you
don't want to move it into a different
place you can just cool it off it'll
push the inactive files into cloud
storage but keep the entire namespace
populated so you know the applications
still see all their data
it's a highly available system if that's
important to you you can either run it
in a single zone or many zones in a
region or all the zones in a region and
even do a synchronous replication across
zones upgrades are automatic and
non-disruptive
and then tearing as I said we can tier
active data into cloud storage you can
also take snapshots of data and store
them directly into Google
cloud storage which is a great thing if
you use storage on premises you know the
traditional filers often you have to
reserve a big chunk of your data for
redundancy and another big chunk of your
capacity for snapshots in this case we
can keep all of the performance capacity
which in our case runs completely in
Google cloud engine and then all any
data for snapshots can be stored into
GCS at a lower cost and keep all of your
primary TR available for performance
okay lastly there's a capability called
Cloud Connect which is a data shipper
for moving data in and out of cloud this
helps solve some of the gap when I have
a large data set on Prem and I'm trying
to figure out how to get it into cloud
we can move all of that and we keep all
the POSIX tough as POSIX em time eight
times see time ACLs any of the metadata
and so you know even to the point where
we can capture hard links and soft links
essentially take a full snapshot of a
data set drop it in Google and start
operating okay so you have two options
you can deploy this in your projects
you manage it we support it or fully
managed service which is effectively
gone to a self-service mode over the
last week
both of these accessible through Google
marketplace the QR codes will get you
there click the link hit go and you're
up and running within a few minutes as a
matter of fact Brian who's going to come
up now and talk about slurm he actually
during the demo used the service to do
to do the implementation so let me hand
off to Brian okay thanks Dave
so I'm Brian Christensen I'm with skadam
D we are the maintainer zuv the open
source workload manager slash job
scheduler so a little bit about slurm
traditionally we find slurm in the more
on the on-premise side so for example in
slurms fire on fire five of the top ten
biggest HP HPC systems in the world and
then also when we're going up into the
top 100 we're over we're on 40 percent
of the top 100 so Sorum scheduling a
wide range of use cases and going from
capability to
cassadee machines and also scheduling a
hybrid of those of those workloads for
example we've got a customer that does
14,000 jobs a minute in a high
throughput environment so so a little
about a little bit about slurm in in the
cloud and where does it fit so a couple
options of having up storm in the cloud
is one you could have slurm as a
standalone clustered all in GCP so you
have your controller your login nodes
and all your compute nodes and and then
with swarm has auto scaling capability
so it'll automatically create and delete
VM instances and GCP according to the
workload and then also so if you've got
an on-premises system you could just
burst out into GCP just extra compute
nodes there and using the auto scaling
capabilities there and then a hybrid
solution of the two is having your
on-premise cluster and a cluster in the
cloud and be able to schedule jobs
submit jobs between the two and and so
we've worked with we've been working
with Google to make it easy to to set up
a a slurm cluster in the cloud easier
and that's that's this reap repo the
slurm GCP repo so okay so we're gonna
jump into the demo the Dave and I
created so Dave explain the demo in the
demo we're gonna set up in a last to
file cluster a slurm cluster and submit
a whole bunch of jobs and watch them run
so we'll show how easy it is to do them
okay so this is the elastic file as a
service we're gonna go ahead and create
that from the market place we're just
gonna give it a go ahead and give it a
name choose our region in the zone we're
gonna head into the east and then
there's some profiles that just kind of
give you some base options how much
capacity
and and then we're gonna choose the the
network that is that it's going to
reside in so we're gonna do the default
one so we're gonna head so that's gonna
go ahead and create we can just spit it
out and the the important thing that
we're looking for right now is this
share name this is the mount point that
we're gonna mount inside of our inside
of our instances so the last a pile is
done we're gonna go ahead and create our
salaam cluster we're going to go to the
repo that we just saw clone it and then
set up the configuration file and inside
the configuration file so I'm gonna set
it up so that we've got a thousand nodes
that we can burst out into and since the
last two file cluster is in the East
we're gonna go ahead and put the cluster
there and our network was the default
one if you don't do the default the
deployment manager will actually create
its own network for it and we're gonna
do eight just to get a bigger bandwidth
and preemptable Burstein that's so that
any node that gets bursted out to is
going to be a preemptable VM and then
this is just for storm accounting so
that it'll run my jobs using my email
address when I a see and when I SSH in
okay so we're gonna do a little bit and
just a little bit more setup so taking
that mountain point and we're gonna this
is this is a script that's going to
mount the last two file service inside
the instances and install some things
for the the e run the Dave talked about
this is the load generator I created by
the last two file and then we're gonna
go ahead and copy that into the
deployment scripts and so when we create
the deployment they'll get pushed up
okay so
we use deployment manager to can create
the instances you're going to see in
deployment manager we created a and now
a router an instance for the controller
an instance for the login node and
you'll also see a instance there's a G
that is the compute image and so what
the compute image is is that it's going
to be a dummy compute node and once it
gets installed then we're gonna make a
snapshot of itself create an image of it
and then any time we burst out we're
gonna use that image so that we can
burst them we can start out vm's a lot
quicker okay so I'm just logging into
the controller will see y'all to make
installs on down here on the bottom
right I'm messy peon just the the script
to do that you run and my team ox comp
okay once that's and once that's
finished installing I'm just going out
to the login node where we're gonna run
the job front and just set up some
monitoring on the side but on the so
here on the right I'm gonna go into the
images page and you'll see that the the
compute image is is creating once that
is completed so while it's building
until it's condemned completing alarm is
Mark the the controller or the the Q or
the partition isn't in a down state so
no jobs can run on it but we see that
nodes are up there we see the slurms
available to run jobs but it's not an
interstate to run them yet until this
computer image finishes once it finishes
it calls home and marks the the Q in the
partition in an upstate so it can run
jobs and once it's up the compute image
image will delete itself and will go
away so here we see that the last two
file amount has been mounted inside at
least the login in
since and it's been mounted and crossed
everywhere so right here I'm submitting
a job that's gonna run on ten notes it's
just gonna run hostname on ten different
nodes and it takes about 45 49 seconds
to finish there and so this will scale
out about every thousand nodes we have
to back off a little bit because we're
hitting API limits but we can spin up
about five thousand nodes and in seven
note and seven minutes here I'm gonna go
ahead and submit the the e run script
and this is an array job and it's going
to be a it's basically it's a thousand
jobs we're gonna spin up a thousand jobs
in each then each job is going to be on
its own compute node so see all the
nodes have been fanned out they're
starting up we see all the compute nodes
being created and on the Left we're just
waiting for them to check in with slurm
and once they check in and while they're
checking in slurm is starting the jobs
so you can see over here in the on the
last two file graphs that they're
starting the filter in you're starting
to run and then we speed up and what
you're gonna see next is a couple of
these VMs are going to get preempted
slurm is going to detect that the the
VMS have been preempted jobs are gonna
get recued jobs that were on those nodes
got recued and so they they become
eligible to run after two minutes and
then slurm will either salaam we go
ahead and restart the the instances when
they've been preempted and then these
jobs are eligible to either run on the
node that it could run on that node that
was preempted or it could
fan out or it could spawn spawn more
nodes to run on so so it was right here
so right now we've run our jobs there
they were ten minute jobs and now we're
going into the the tail of it and this
is just finishing off the the
preemptable x'
the the preemptable jobs and then what
else what we're also going to see to is
all these compute nodes are gonna clean
themselves off after they've been idle
for a default of five minutes slurm will
start tearing them down so so we we spun
up a thousand a thousand nodes and they
all checked in within about three
minutes and they completed the and then
the preemptable is tailed off
so pretty simple to set up a last to
file cluster in an Islamic luster in GCP
right on yeah and actually Brian did all
that work pretty much by himself yeah
when we started coordinating the demo he
went and grabbed I showed him how to
find a last file and then he came back
and said okay I already built all of it
it all works so a testament of an
end-user to a large extent so
essentially what we just saw to recap
that is his Brian said three minutes we
had a thousand jobs queued and another
thousand machines created and as you saw
as they showed up work we're starting to
fly through the system so super fast and
even at that job we sped it up a little
bit for times sake you know no one on
Justin wants to watch a cake cooking but
in that short amount of time I think it
was up for 15 minutes maybe total from
start to finish about one percent of the
thousand machines were preempted and a
preemptable machine lasts for max 24
hours right whether it's a GP or CPU
based but even still in that short
amount of time they were lost and so we
did a we did a session with an HPC
session last year with silicon
therapeutics using GPUs that were
preemptable and they didn't have this
feature you guys hadn't released your
feature yet was slurm and so every day
he had to go in and riku all of these
jobs with a manual you know process to
find what broke and fix it all so that's
a really great thing and then most
importantly you know if you've ever been
caught in the the cloudy issue which is
a month later I forgot to turn off all
these machines slurm prevents all of
that a left no trace as soon as the jobs
are idle it cleaned them up and you know
the billing stops immediately which is
great your accountants will like that so
a thousand machines spun up parallel NFS
running very simple configuration he
didn't have to install any storage stuff
it just works out of the box we were
sustaining two and a half gigabytes of
sustained throughput through the system
and all of the data that was written in
those jobs was persisted even though
when it preemptable goes down the data
gets deleted so that's the net of that
you know we've took preemptable machines
which by nature are non persistent and
unpredictable and when they're gonna go
up and down and we eliminated the the
unpredict
ability of the the non-persistent of
data we added slurm and added this extra
predictability and sort of accounting
cleanup right so we could deliver
reliability predictability for HPC now
lastly you know the question is hey
that's great
but what's the cost and so we ran the
numbers to make sure that you know this
is actually achievable and it's
essentially the cost impact is
negligible if you look at you know the
total cost when running large HPC
systems most of it is compute oriented
so if you compare a standard compute
based system to preemptable zyou you
know typically are about they're about
80 percent less expensive you add in
slurm and alas the file we did a model
over a week and you know it was just a
few percent difference in the total
price so your savings are still 75 to 79
percent over what a standard deployment
would look like Michelle thank you guys
now we know how I'll know how to utilize
the cost savings of the beauty of
pre-emptive machines as well as getting
our job done in a timely fashion and if
you like to learn more about lots of
file take a photo of this we'll have a
session tomorrow all right oh sorry
there you go let me wrap this session
with a user story this user is extremely
special to us because it is our own
engineering design team our own
semiconductor chip team and that's why
we call the story a Google on Google
story although this is a Google
semiconductor chip engineering team but
our engineering team resonates you know
that they have the same problems their
design the design based on same
principles they use the same tools as
everybody else on in the world so in
case you're not familiar with
semiconductor chip design right you lay
out a hardware design and then you put
in some boundary conditions input
conditions and you simulate the design
first
when you're happy with the final
simulation results you send that
blueprint to a manufacturer to be
manufactured and then the manufacturers
and the sample chips back and you
measure them and to see if the results
are exactly how you designed it and the
results are what you're expecting if not
likely you have to go back and we tweak
the design right and then send it back
to the factory now probably beta and
then factory send the sample chip back
you measure it again so this whole
iteration takes one year to year easily
several years easily so our chip design
team is thinking there has to be a way
where we can reduce the engineering
design cycle and so they decided to move
to the cloud and just like everybody
else in the world they're thinking we
don't want to refactor our workflow we
do what we do not want to read to our
system and at the same time we all we
want all of the benefits from the cloud
so in the early stage of their workflow
migration they've decided that ok we'll
keep our interactive sessions on Prem
and it will keep majority of our
repositories on Prem and now when it
comes to batch jobs right we need to
launch thousands of them and we don't
even have this amount of machine
on-premises so we'll do that in the
cloud and if you're familiar with you
know semiconductor chip design or if you
have paid attention to some of the jobs
you have ran in the past you will notice
that some jobs require more CPUs some
require more frequencies summary part a
more memory and so our own design team
you know when they looked at the
profiler jobs they decided to use custom
machine types which is a product that's
available in Google cloud today so
custom machine types really it's a cost
saving plate right so you don't over
provision
and then they're using containers
because you know it's easy to deploy
easier to manage and our own team is
also you know as we just saw in the demo
demo earlier by Alaska file as well as
learn we saw that if we're able to
manage preemptable VMs properly we can
actually have quite a bit of cost saving
and also be very efficient with our
engineering design cycle and lastly and
probably the most importantly is
security and compliance
you know those Hardware layouts are
extremely sensitive and our team has the
same concerns as everybody else in the
world so I'll flash this very high level
architectural design that our own teams
deployment has today in Google Cloud on
the left is their on premises deployment
you know its standard compute plus some
storage components and it's connected to
Google cloud through VPN and in their
cloud they will have these staged their
jobs you know when it comes to job
staging right you have your design files
inputs parameters boundary conditions
all loaded in cloud storage and then
they will have different persistent
disks to look to load different design
tools and then eventually all the
computation is done in either custom
machine types containers or just normal
VMs that are available on Google Cloud
today and so this work was actually done
before the C 2 and M twos were announced
or made available to our customers so
you know the C 2 are the high frequency
ones I am curious at 12 turbines so I
highly suspect our own team might go in
and try our own C 2 and I'm 2 machines
very soon so that is all the content we
have today for everyone and thank you
for joining us and so to recap we are no
longer limited by what computers we have
in our labs we're no longer limited by
where the computers are time has changed
we're in the era where engineers are
and Howard we're more efficient at what
we do and so we can clear our room in
our schedules right so we can solve more
problems and make bigger impacts in the
world
thank you we have a HPC link here if you
want to check out the content and assets
we have today
[Music]